a train pulls into the Czech Republic
town of bringing us an echo of another
commission by Oskar Shindler a story
commemorated in the film Schindler's
List Schindler brought 1200 GS workers
here saving many from the Nazi death
camps this site was given to Schindler
thanks to his ties with the secret
police originally a textile factory the
workers incarcerated inside these walls
made components for Germany's war
machine after the war the Communists
took over Czechoslovakia and this
Factory was nationalized these new
additions were added and it went back to
making textiles car seat covers for
Skoda 2004 after the collapse of
communism the factory went bankrupt the
factories now for sale the town's mayor
has a vision to honor those who labored
here dented Omiya so chaski with his
house where Schindler used to live with
his wife who will be a part of the
future exhibition commemorating the
suffering of Jews in this concentration
camp during World War two the podcast
yeah you know it is only a small part of
the entire factory complex which we
would like to clean up in order to
restore production and create jobs for
the people in this region in our theater
musical battle minista
reviving this Factory may seem like an
insurmountable task but the mayor's
hopeful investors will show interest and
that Jewish groups may help fund the
museum and keep this history from being
forgotten
David tweed Bloomberg bringing its Czech
Republic